hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast detection of circulating
tumor biomarkers using the fire flex
technology platform presented by Daniel
Craig one general manager of platform
innovation of app cam incorporation I am
Marjorie torres of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labrys and
sponsored by ab camp for more
information about our sponsor please
visit www.hp.com/recycle mind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation and the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Daniel preggers blonde I
will now turn the presentation over to
him all right thank you so much for the
introduction my name is Lenore agribon
i'm the general manager of platform
innovation at ab cam today i'm going to
be talking about the platform that my
group has been developing over the past
few years for biomarker detection and
specifically some of the applications
around cancer
so as therapeutics become better and
better for many diseases specifically
cancer we're realizing that the onus is
really placed now on early diagnosed
early diagnosis of the disease so a
critical pain point and research in
medicine is really the discovery and the
validation of stable reproducible
biomarkers that come from minimally
invasive samples like plasma serum
saliva or urine proteins are the
traditional biomarkers and specifically
circulating proteins and plasma or serum
have been used or attempted to be used
for clinical screening of cancer some
examples of this are ca-125 that have
been used for ovarian cancer in women
and prostate serum antigen which has
used been used for prostate cancer in
men and of course these are single
molecule biomarkers and so theoretically
they are the most easily interpreted now
the problem with this is that as the
field progresses we are learning that
single protein biomarkers are really
proving to be insufficient to describe
very complex diseases like cancer and as
we learn more about disease we're
learning more about how the different
analyte classes interplay to not only
tell you what the current disease state
is in a patient but where the disease is
going so what we're learning now is that
biomarker signatures that utilize
multiple targets and more importantly
look across multiple analyte classes
will likely yield the most robust
diagnostic indicators for future
diagnosis so micro rna's are for the
last three years have become the
emerging biomarkers and in comparison to
their protein counterparts their ideals
and their ideal in many ways
specifically they have short known
sequences and they're largely conserved
across species they actually regulate
most of the genes in our bodies and
what's interesting about micro RNAs
is that a single micro RNA instead of
regulating a single gene can actually
regulate tens or even hundreds of genes
they're highly stable in biofluids
they're also highly stable for storage
reasons
so typically micro rna's are coupled
with proteins that protect them from RNA
degradation or they are hidden in
membranes and micro vesicles or exosomes
an interesting aspect of micro rna's is
that they have tissue specific
signatures so if there is a tissue
specific indication or effect of a
disease or a therapeutic that can be
detected via micro rna's and as we'll
talk about significantly today there are
disease specific signatures especially
in cancer where micro rna's really got
their first look into diagnosis so micro
rna's have been published quite
extensively in cancer and in cancer
metastasis when micro endings were first
discovered the first diagnoses were done
in solid tumors where people would
digest a tissue extract the RNA and look
at differential expression of micro RNAs
and tumor versus healthy tissue but as
of about 2008 where we discovered that
migrant RNAs are actually found in
circulation we realized that there is
much more potential for a minimally
invasive bio fluid to be obtained and to
diagnose cancer via circulating micro
RNAs and so much of the focus today is
really on micro RNAs that are in
circulation interestingly not just for
diagnosis micro rna's are also being
investigated for use in therapeutics or
to monitor the response to various
therapies so certainly they are they are
seeing quite a large spread use as far
as cancer diagnosis and therapy
not just with microRNAs but with any
biomarker they all follow a pretty
similar development pipeline which is
broken up into three main stages
discovery qualification and verification
and lastly validation and clinical
implementation the discovery phase can
be akin to casting a very large net
typically researchers want to look at
all of the possible biomarkers of
interest and they want to do this over a
handful of different samples
representing various cohorts and the
idea in the discovery phase is to do a
very deep dive on a few samples to
identify a few candidates that could be
used in a biomarker signature after
discovery phase was typically yielded
are 10 to maybe hundreds of different
analyte candidates for for use in
diagnosis and what's done in the
qualification and verification stage is
to use these targets but to take a much
broader dive into many many different
samples so typically what we'll look at
for qualification and verification are
tens to hundreds of targets but we'll do
this over hundreds of samples finally
once we get the statistical rigor that
we would need to take this any further
and consider clinical implementation we
would then move into a validation phase
where now we have maybe narrowed down
our target signature to four to maybe
ten analytes and instead of looking at
hundreds of samples now we're going to
look at much broader classes of samples
and we're specifically going to do this
over many different sample types and
many different patients to really get a
snapshot of the heterogeneity that we
typically see with patient cohorts so
again we'll look at maybe spend four to
ten different analytes and we'll do this
over a thousands of samples before we
decide if this is clinically relevant
so now we'll take a little bit of a dive
at you're looking at the fireplace
biomarker profiling platform that my
team has been working on the fire flex
platform was really designed to be a
versatile multiplexing tool that allows
researchers to perform multiplexing with
instrumentation that they currently own
one of the nice things about the
platform it was specifically designed
for detection directly from crude
digests of bio fluids and tissue so we
have developed our assays such that we
do not require for instance micro RNA
purification or total RNA purification
we could simply digest a sample and that
detect micro nays directly in that
sample the assay also works with very
complex sample types including heparin
plasma X's ohms formalin-fixed tissues
and even dried blood spots for example
we have a versatile platform in that we
can perform multiplex detection of micro
rna's and we can also detect enough
proteins and it's versatile also in the
fact that our assays are completely
customizable and that we work with
researchers to build the exact panel
that they need for their specific
application again it was designed
specifically for used in biomarker
discovery and verification we work with
researchers who are looking to do
hundreds of micro rna's over a few
samples or those who are looking to take
a deeper dive at tens of micro neighs
and to hundreds of samples so we have
really designed the platform to spread
the entire biomarker development
pipeline
lastly we know that capital equipment is
somewhat of a constraint especially in
research settings so we have designed
the assay for readout on standard
instrumentation and the first system
that we looked at was a standard flow
cytometry the platform is based on
encoded hydrogel particles and with
these particles were able to do in well
multiplexing typically up to 65 barcodes
for micro RNAs in a single well or 75
bar codes for proteins as shown in the
middle of the slides our particles are
rod shaped and have three functional
zones the two end
regions of the particle we put different
levels of fluorescence in those regions
and those act as a barcode which will
then identify the analyte that is being
quantified in the probe region that is
in the center of the particle now in
every well will have multiple copies of
different particles with different
barcodes that are detecting their
corresponding analytes so we can have
robust measurement again of up to 65
micro rna's in a well or 75 proteins an
interesting thing about the platform is
that we built this on inert hydrogel
substrates now this is very different to
the glass counterpart the u18 a
microarray or polystyrene that you would
see in a bead because in a hydrogel we
actually have binding in a
three-dimensional volume this gives us
optimal thermodynamics but also gives us
a very large dynamic range for detection
and because the hydrogel is bio inert
this also allows us to detect directly
from crude biofluids without the need to
do any blocking step in BSA or anything
else again we have a very versatile
chemistry that we can apply to the
particle and this really allows us to
adapt the particles the specific need
and to use them across different target
classes and again as we already
mentioned we perform readout on a
standard flow cytometry and the way this
is done is that our rod shape will flow
past the detection zone of a site ometer
which would then think that the rod is
actually comprised of three closely
spaced cells that are going by the
interrogation region so each one of our
particles that goes through a flow
cytometry is detected as three events
that is later decoded using our software
so to have a quick look at what the
software offering is we provide instant
bioinformatics with our fire flex
analysis workbench now this is a Java
based piece of software that really runs
anywhere it has simple point-and-click
GUI and it doesn't require any any
scripts this will allow you to layout
your experiment be it across multiple
targets and multiple plates that allow
you to easily import those data for a
quick interpretation and analysis we
allow a broad range of visualization
from heat maps to bar plots to volcano
plots and also provide statistical
information as far as ANOVA analysis
across cohorts we talk about p-values
and we also provide corrected p-values
that take into account the multiplexing
that is performed in these assays all of
the images are a publication ready and
they can be scaled to meet your needs
another really interesting piece of
software that we're developing and this
is really for researchers who are unsure
of which targets they want to they want
to quantify in their multiplex assay we
have the fire flex discovery engine and
what this allows researchers to do is to
type in their field of interest and with
the click of a button what the software
does it will actually analyze the most
recent publications in that area to
provide a word cloud of the micro rna's
that have been most recently published
that will provide the the genes of
interest that are also published in
those papers and they'll also provide
you a list of authors that are actively
publishing in the area and all of these
microRNAs and keywords are clickable
such that you can dig in deeper and see
how those micro rna's were referenced in
the various papers or to see an
annotated list of the publications just
I encourage you to check that out now
we'll talk a little bit more about the
nuts and bolts of we have a platform but
how do we actually use the platform to
quantify micro RNAs and proteins
this is a snapshot of the protocol that
we use for micro RNA detection and it's
really broken into four main stages and
the first stage we will hybridize micro
RNAs and a crude digest of a sample with
our micro particles in the well of a
microtiter plate we will then perform a
labeling step we will then allude off
the labeled micro RNAs and amplify it
via universal PCR will then transfer the
amplicon back on to our particles where
we will hybridize add a reporter for
fluorescence and scan them on again a
standard flow cytometer and lastly as I
mentioned these flow cytometer files can
be loaded into our software for
instantaneous analysis now we'll take a
look at the molecular workflow in the
probe region of our micro RNA detection
particles we have an all of a nucleotide
probe that has three regions on it the
central region of the probe is specific
for a given micro RNA target and the to
end regions are specific for universal
adapters that will then be ligated on 2d
micro rna's so in the first step again
we are capturing a specific micro RNA
onto each specific particle that is
floating in the micro well we will then
ligate these universal adapters onto the
ends of the micro rnas and again it's
important to note that for each micro
RNA these adapters are the same such
that once we aleut off those labelled
micro rna's we can perform an
amplification with the same primer pair
and this was really designed to try and
avoid any sequence bias that you might
see in typical PCR where you would have
a different set of primers for each
micro NAT is being amplified after we've
amplified the sample we will then
rehydrate it back onto the same
particles that were used for the initial
capture and again this provides two
layers of specificity and that we have
two unique hybridization steps to ensure
that we are hybridizing the correct
target to the correct particle before
read out
after we've hybridized those by 10
elated amplicons we will then label with
a fluorescent reporter again and we will
read out on a standard flow cytometry
now in order to assess the sensitivity
of the platform I always think it's most
useful to look at the amount of sample
that is required for detection in a
given modality so the way we looked at
this we took two reference panels to
detect micro rna's either in crude serum
or in total RNA that was purified from a
tissue sample so what we look at for
crude serum we looked at an input of 40
microliters down to approximately 5
microliters of input and the targets
that we were assessing here we're either
very abundant moderately abundant or low
the abundant in those samples and what
we see is that when dropping off from 40
to 20 to 10 microliters of serum we're
still robustly detecting most of the
targets in our reference panel again
showing very high highly sensitive
detection of micro RNAs which are
already very rare and serum samples to
begin with now in terms of total RNA
while most platforms typically look at
micro gram or certainly nano gram levels
of input for their assay we are
measuring our input here in terms of
picograms so we started off with two
point five nanograms and Aleutians down
all the way down to for Kika grams and
what we're showing here is robust
detection of a good number of targets
all the way down to just tens of Pico
grams of total RNA that was input so
again this just goes to show that even
though we're technical we still have a
very highly sensitive assay another
interesting aspect of the platform is
that unlike traditional qPCR our system
is intolerant to PCR inhibitors one that
always comes up is heparin so what we
did is using the same patients we did a
single blood draw and collected into
multiple different tubes where we had k2
EDTA sodium citrate or sodium pepperin
and what we're showing here is that
regardless of the anticoagulant or the
preservative that we used were able to
show very robust
action of all the targets and very very
strong correlation across the different
collection methods so again this just
goes to show that the assay because we
are washing away any remnants of the
sample before we move on to the labeling
and detection step we are very robust
and resistant to traditional issues that
you might see with standard qPCR when
first launching the platform it was very
important for us to do a platform
comparison where we have found that a
lot of the researchers that we work with
are actually using multiple platforms to
do orthogonal studies just to show
validation across multiple platforms to
really take that piece out of the
equation so what we did is we use some
of the most common platforms that we we
see our collaborators working with and
those include qPCR and also Illumina
sequencing we looked at three different
types of tissue and we purified RNA from
brain lung and liver and what we did is
we measure the fold change of each
target relative to the average of that
target across the given samples and then
use these fold changes to compare
platform to platform now something
interesting to note here is that the
sequencing in order to perform that
study we had to use one microgram of
input RNA for qPCR using the tilde cards
we had to input 16 anagrams and with our
platform we were able to use only five
nanograms but I showed on previous
slides we very well could have gone much
lower than that and even with these very
very small amount of total RNA input
we're still showing excellent
correlation with both sequencing and
qpcr and we typically see Pearson's
above 0.9 our micro RNA offering again
is really designed to address all of the
biomarker development pipeline we have
developed discovery panels that will
allow researchers to look at about 400
circulating micro RNAs these are all
selected from peer review studies
we also have customizable discovery
panels for rodent immunology or plasma
and serum markers now for a more
moderate panel that might be used as
something like verification we have
focus panels and these are comprised of
65 micro rna's that have been selected
for multiple research areas including
tissue toxicity oncology immunology
cardiology and neurology lastly for the
researchers who are studying novel
markers or combinations thereof we do
allow for the complete customization of
panels any micro RNA das annotated Anmer
base we can build a custom panel and
turn that around very rapidly again it
can be comprised of anywhere from 5 to
up to 65 micro RNAs in a single panel
and just briefly because we have talked
about the importance of looking at
multiple analytes to diagnose disease
well look into our multiplex
immunoassays now these are performed as
a standard sandwich assay where we'll
have a capture antibody that is attached
in the probe region of a given barcode
as hydrogel particle will then capture a
target and will include a detection
antibody that has a fluorescent on it
for detection once a sandwich is built
on a particle again all of these assays
can be read out on the standard flow
cytometry they are all built in a
pick-and-mix format meaning we have a
broad variety of content that can be
included in the platform and researchers
are able to then pick and mix which
targets are most relevant to their
research an important thing to note that
distinguishes our immunoassays for most
others is that as app cam we are very
good at making our own antibodies and
because of that we are building rabbit
monoclonal antibodies and we're
predominantly using these to build our
multiplex immunoassays and the rabbit
monoclonal have really been shown to
provide the best sensitivity and
specificity possible for these types of
studies
and just to show a little comparison of
our multiplexed immunoassay versus other
suppliers on bead based assays we're
showing here for the 15 most important
human cytokines we typically see a much
broader dynamic range and in all cases
we're seeing very good sensitivity
compared to other suppliers similar to
our micro rna's we do offer some
pre-built tools and also some custom
tools for researchers to do the type of
study that they need for instance we
provide specific panels for cytokine
release syndrome we also have a panel
for immuno oncology we have panels for
toxicity and again we allow the
customization by pick-and-mix of any of
the content that we currently offer in
our portfolio so now that we've looked
at the platform and the assays that
we've put on the platform what we did is
we're going to summarize a couple of the
research studies that have been
performed using the system and again
these are in the area of cancer we're
the first one we'll look at was
performed by a swiss group where they
were looking at non small cell lung
cancer and they were looking to see if
they can identify a signature of
microRNAs that could be indicative of
the overall survival of these patients
so I'm sure this audience knows quite a
bit about lung cancer but just to point
out a few things
lung cancer accounts for about a third
of all cancer related deaths and with a
five-year survival rate of only 2% it's
a pretty difficult disease to deal with
now chemotherapy is known to improve
clinical outcome of non-small-cell lung
cancer but as is the case with many
cancers it's really dependent on the
correct disease classification and
patient stratification
there have been some previous studies
that have indicated that micro RNA
signatures could potentially be used to
classify and prognosis biomarkers by the
prognostic biomarkers of non-small cell
lung cancer and so the aim of this study
was to really dig deeper into that and
to perform a multiply multi-site
prospective clinical trial with the main
goal of really identifying circulating
microRNAs that can be used as prognostic
markers of overall survival now
alongside this there were a couple other
goals of the study and they were to
identify micro RNA signatures that were
potentially related to disease
stabilisation they looked at micro RNAs
that could be indicative of tumor
shrinkage or the time to disease
progression following chemotherapy so
just very briefly these studies were
performed using patch teen blood again
they looked at 50 patients and they
monitor those patients over time and of
the key findings in this study what they
did is a traditional biomarker
development where they looked at
thirteen hundred and forty seven micro
rna's in the discovery phase and from
those they identified ten micro rna's
that were associated with overall
survival and most significantly of those
was micro na 29a and as shown in the
kaplan-meier plot to the right those
patients that had a very high expression
of mer 29a and circulation actually had
the the poorest outcome secondly they
found 12 12 micro rna's that were
associated with tumor shrinkage and of
those the most significant was micro na
665 as shown in the plot here with the
higher expression level of that micro
RNA they actually saw a greater
percentage of tumor shrinkage
lastly they found 10 micro rna's that
were associated with the time to disease
progression and again the main player
here seem to be micro in a 223 and again
higher levels of mer 223 correspond to
the poorest outcomes for those patients
so it's interesting here that we're
looking at three very different
measurements and of those measurements
we're finding three micro RNAs that seem
to be the key players in each now the
next study that we looked at was a
little bit different instead of just
diagnosing the disease this is more of a
mechanistic view of the micro RNA 200
family and specifically the role in
metastasis and how extracellular
vesicles play a role in this whole
system so metastasis in this case they
were looking at breast cancer where
metastasis is the major cause of
mortality previously research has shown
that the micro and 8200 family which
includes 200 ABC 429 and mer 141 have
been shown to regulate epithelial to
mesenchymal transition which is
obviously a very key step in in cancer
spread so tumor cells are known to
actually secrete a large amount of
extracellular vesicles and again
depending on their size and their place
of origin these are referred to as
exosomes exosomes micro particles etc
but here we'll just broadly call them
extracellular vesicles so tumor cells
are known to secrete a very large amount
of these extracellular vesicles which
contain all sorts of biomolecules
including proteins messenger rnas micro
rna's etc so even though there have been
hypotheses it's never been shown that
extracellular vesicles can confer
metastatic properties to cells that
would otherwise be poorly metastatic in
vivo
so with no surprise the main objective
of this study was to see if that was the
case can we determine if micro RNA is
transferred by extracellular vesicles do
indeed confirm metastatic properties on
cells that would otherwise be poorly
metastatic the research was actually
broken into a series of multiple
experimental chunks where they look at
some of the mechanisms both in vitro and
in vivo and in this case they build a
very comprehensive study to prove their
points they performed several
fundamental experiments to really drive
to the conclusion that these
observations are directly related to the
micro RNA 200 family and that they're
also related to those family members
that are packaged in extracellular
vesicles so for example they looked at
some knockouts where the mer 200 family
was not expressed to see if the results
were the same they also looked at RNA
s-- digestion of samples to ensure that
what they were looking at were actually
micro rna's that were packaged in
membranes and not those that were
free-floating in solution so again they
did a very comprehensive study to
demonstrate their key results now some
of the key findings of a study were that
the micro RNA 200 family is in fact
elevated and metastatic cancer cell
lines so in this case we're looking at
Mouse cell lines from a tumor and we
have 41 cells that are very metastatic
4007 and 67 NR cells that are not that
metastatic and what we're showing in
this heat map are that the 41 cells are
actually expressing a much higher level
of number 200 family compared to the non
metastatic cell counterparts another
interesting finding is that the
extracellular vesicles that are being
secreted from those cells also show
higher levels of mer 200
now this is interesting that the results
specifically state that the micro rna's
in the extracellular vesicles in this
case are very similar to the abundance
of those that are in the cell lines
themselves so there does not seem to be
any preferential packaging of microRNAs
into the accelerator vesicles according
to this study next what they showed
showed is that poorly metastatic cells
those that are Co incubated with
metastatic cells will actually take on
the metastatic properties of those
metastatic cells so they did this with a
couple different experiments where they
either Co incubated in a homogeneous
format or they looked at a trans well
format where the cells were not in
contact and in both cases they were able
to show that the non metastatic cells
took on the metastatic properties of
those metastatic cells and again the
hypothesis is that this is accomplished
by the transfer of this micro RNA 200
family via via exercise of their
vesicles so then moving into the in vivo
studies what they did is they had
several mice with various cancers and
they were shown they showed that the
mice that had the metastatic tumors
actually did show an elevated micro RNA
200 family level in circulation and
lastly and I think most interestingly in
mouse and human xenograph models they
were showing that metastatic cell lines
again with high mer 200 family
expression were able to transfer the
metastatic properties to nearby cells
but also to very distant sites again
really supporting this notion that the
micro and a 200 family transferred by
extracellular vesicles can be a major
cause of cancer metastasis in living
models
so again I encourage you to look at both
of these studies I think they did a
really good job of utilizing the
platform and developing biomarkers to
show very specific outcomes so I
encourage you to have a look and have a
deeper read for some of the specific
studies done therein now with that I
just want to summarize and again kind of
highlight the uses of the fire flex
platform and really the most appropriate
settings where the fire flex platform
was designed to work with a very limited
sample volume again with only 20
microliters as a standard input we can
typically detect 65 micro RNAs with only
12 and half microliters input for four
proteins we can detect up to 75 barcodes
in that case also we work very well with
crude samples we can detect micro rna's
directly from crude digests a bio fluid
we can also work with very difficult
samples like heparin FFPE CSF and we
demonstrated hair detection in exosomes
again pointing to biomarker development
we work in high throughput settings or
high Plex settings for those researchers
who are looking to do discovery to cast
a very broad net over a few samples we
do that very well but we were really
designed for these high-throughput
assays where we're looking at one
hundreds or thousands of samples and we
want to do that over tens of targets we
have build a whole software suite that
really helps streamline the bio and
traumatic and statistical analysis and
lastly as I said before this platform is
really designed to be fully customizable
so if you have a study that looks at ten
proteins or a thousand micro rna's or
some combination thereof the fire flex
platform was really put in place to help
you and with that I thank you for your
time and I open it up to any questions
thank you dr. president for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is what is
the recommended input of biofluids that
you use for the mi RNA Ave this is a
really good question and it typically
depends on if we're performing a
discovery study or if we're doing a more
focused study nominally what we
recommend as an input is 40 microliters
of your your bio fluid and this is then
digested with an additional 40
microliters of our digest buffer and
with this cumulative eighty microliters
what we can actually do is perform a
triplicate analysis for most bio fluids
now in the case of our discovery panel
where we're looking at maybe 400 targets
instead of just 65 we typically
recommend a higher starting amount and
this has a lot to do with the fact that
it's offered currently as a service we
want to make sure the samples are stable
when being shipped so again we ask for a
larger volume such that in handling
these samples we do have enough to input
into the assay but again nominally
really depending on the sample we
typically recommend anywhere from 40
microliters maybe even down to 10
microliters of bio fluid thank you for
that answer our next question is what
type of site ohmmeter does your platform
work with another good question and
again the platform was made to be as
versatile as possible so we have tested
over a broad number of flow cytometry
and the minimum requirement really is
that the system has we prefer to have a
single blue laser and three colors for
detectors including green yellow and red
but we have worked with a number of
Becton Dickinson Saitama ters we've
worked with Beckman Coulter the Acura
even the Miller Park wobba system all
worked very well with our platform so we
encourage you if you have a question
about a specific site ometer please get
in touch with us and and we'll tell you
about the compatibility studies that
have been done I would like to once
again thank dr. Daniel prattle on turn
his presentation I would also like to
thank him for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2017 you will receive
an email from labyrinth letting you in
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye